[Musique]
à l'occasion du 80ème anniversaire du
rétablissement de la République une
plaque commémorative a été inaugurée au
collège de la montagne en novembre 1942
la Réunion est libérée après avoir été
sous le régime de Vichy pendant 29 mois
l'appel général de Gaulle a été entendu
dans toute la France
résonne dans le monde mais
lorsque la Réunion
petit territoire de l'océan Indien
et ce territoire où René la République
et bien ça aussi ça mérite d'être connu
par le plus grand nombre de Français
une plaque à la mémoire de Raymond de
Cugy directeur du Service des travaux
publics de la Réunion tu es le 28
novembre 1942 pendant la libération de
Lille nous avons voulu rendre hommage
aux morts de la ville de Saint-Denis à
l'établissement qui se trouve le plus
proche du lieu où de cugis est tombé
assassiné sans sommation par les balles
des miliciens de tennis sur la route de
la montagne nous avons souhaité que ceux
qui ont donné leur vie ceux qui ont
donné leur sang pour la liberté pour
notre liberté que leurs souvenirs
puissent être rappelé
pour les collégiens de connaître leur
propre histoire et de comprendre que la
réunion a été un point d'ancrage pour la
restauration de la République
[Musique]